bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat enfin une embellie sur
le plan macroéconomique
c'est en tout cas le message que veut
faire passer christian eckert
le secrétaire d'état au budget était
auditionné hier après midi par les
sénateurs de la commission des affaires
sociales avec un mot à la bouche
réduction en effet le déficit du régime
général de la sécurité sociale et
s'établit à 9,7 milliards d'euros pour
l'année 2014
c'est 2 milliards de mieux que les
prévisions
et c'est la première fois depuis 2008
que ce chiffre passe sous la barre
symbolique des 10 milliards d'euros
alors christian eckert a raison de ne
pas bouder son plaisir mais attention
derrière les annonces derrière les
éléments de langage il faut voir que ce
chiffre de 9,7 milliards d'euros c'est
le déficit uniquement pour l'année 2014
c'est un flux qui vient alimenter le
trou béant de la sécurité sociale la
dette sociale qui elle se chiffre en
centaines de milliards d'euros attention
donc à ce qui se cache derrière les
annonces on découvre tout de suite cette
audition merci
présence de bien sûr pour écouter
auditionné monsieur christian kert
inquiets secrétaires d'état chargés du
budget auprès du ministre des finances
et des comptes publics qui a bien voulu
répondre à notre invitation m'est
d'ailleurs c'est ce que vous aviez aussi
su gérer je pense que c'est une
rencontre qui a souhaité lors de la
présentation du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
notre président qui s'excuse qui est
retenue comme vous l'imaginez dans son
département et pour les raisons que vous
savez
avait indiqué madame la ministre des
affaires sociales qui souhaitait qu'un
suivi plus régulier de l'exécution de
ces textes soient assurées par notre
commission
donc comme vous le savez n'existe pas de
loi de règlement de finances pour les
finances sociales plus exactement la
première partie de la loi de financement
porte sur le dernier exercice clos sans
faire l'objet d'un texte autonome si
vous avez présenté à monsieur le
ministre les résultats de l'exercice
2014 pour le budget de l'état devant nos
collègues de la commission des finances
le 28 janvier dernier il faut près d'un
semestre pour collecter les résultats
des régimes obligatoires de base de la
sécurité sociale ils ne se sont ils ne
sont pas donc de fait pleinement
disponible et donc lors de la commission
des comptes de la sécurité seront
disponibles plus exactement pardon lors
de la commission des comptes de sécurité
sociale de juin dans cette longue
séquence cependant les différentes
branches du régime général clôturent
leurs comptes à la mi mars avec des
résultats qui donnent des très largement
le don de l'exécution de la loi de
financement
à cet égard je dois dire que les
résultats publiés la semaine dernière
nous ont surpris la loi de financement
pour 2014 est l'une des rares dans
l'histoire des lois de financement avoir
fait l'objet d'une rectification à mi
année et cette rectification nous avait
plutôt préparer à une stagnation des
déficits dus à un niveau de recettes
insuffisant
sous l'effet d'une conjoncture dégradée
alors même que ni le niveau de
croissance qui est de 0,4 contre 1% en
prévision ni celui de l'inflation qui
est nul contre 1,2 pour cent en
prévision ni celui de la masse salariale
du secteur privé qui est de 1,2 pour
cent contre 2,2 en provisions je pense
que je confirmerai ces chiffres ne sont
conformes aux attentes
les recettes semble t'il progressé sont
supérieures de plus d'un milliard
d'euros aux prévisions ce que vous avez
fait
annoncées du côté des dépenses la loi de
financement rectificative avait procédé
à un repassage important de l'ondam
avant que les inquiétudes se fasse jour
sur les dépenses d'indemnités
journalières et de mérite de médicaments
en vie
là encore les annonces de la semaine
dernière relève d'amis un milliard
d'euros de moindres dépenses dans ce
contexte monsieur le ministre votre
audition vous comprendrez est
particulièrement bienvenu pour analyser
toutes ces données et vous donne bien
sûr et a volontiers la parole oui merci
monsieur le président merci mesdames
messieurs les rapporteurs des
commissaires c'est que cette période un
peu particulière mais en tout cas je
vais m'efforcer de d'abord présenté non
pas les comptes définitifs je vais y
revenir mais et des prévisions très fine
je crois que nous sommes en mesure de de
communiqué aujourd'hui
et bien sûr je me fonds serait de
répondre à vos questions
il tombe bien entendu que sur les lois
de financement de la sécurité sociale
vous savez que c'est souvent une partie
se joue un peu à deux entre certains
états au budget chargé des comptes
publics et la ministre des affaires
sociales puisqu'il ya des partis qui
concerne plus spécifiquement bien sûr
ses compétences au sens propre du terme
le 17 mars dernier nous avons rendu
publics les chiffres des comptes
définitifs du régime général de sécurité
sociale et du fsv qui ont été clos le
même jour par les organismes même s'ils
n'ont pas encore été certifiés par la
cour des comptes
je précise à titre liminaire qu'il ne
s'agit là que des comptes du régime
général est que nous ne disposons pas
encore à cette date des résultats de
l'ensemble des régimes de base de la
sécurité sociale dont le solde sera
toutefois très proche de celui du régime
général c'est souvent toujours j'allais
dire comme ça
de même nous ne disposons pas encore
durer
utah définitif de l'ondam 2014 même si
le résultat des dépenses de la branche
maladie du régime général et des
branches d'intégrer nous permet déjà de
savoir qu'il sera respecté ce qui est un
résultat très important
par ailleurs et toujours à titre
liminaire je rappelle que les comptes
ont été arrêtés voici quelques jours
seulement et que nous n'avons évidemment
pas encore pu procéder à une analyse
complète de toutes les raisons qui
expliquent le résultat financier même si
nous en avons bien sûr un certain nombre
ce sera l'objet comme chaque année des
travaux de la commission des comptes de
la sécurité sociale 2 juin à laquelle
d'ailleurs plusieurs d'entre vous
participez régulièrement ces préalables
étant posé je voudrais développer trois
idées principalement concernant les
comptes de 2014 tout d'abord le déficit
continue à se réduire
et ceci dans une ampleur plus importante
que prévu vous l'avez évoqué j'y
reviendrai
deuxième idée c'est que cela s'explique
pour partie par une excellente maîtrise
des dépenses de l'ensemble des branches
grâce aux efforts réalisés sur le
système de protection sociale et ceci
sans remettre en cause le financement de
nos priorités est troisième et dernier
point c'est que ce bon résultat
s'explique vous l'avez aussi évoqué par
des recettes qui se sont finalement bien
tenu malgré la croissance plus faible
que le niveau anticipé au départ ce qui
prouve la prudence que le gouvernement a
eu dans ses prévisions financières
sur le premier point je reviens sur le
résultat bons résultats de l'année 2014
avec un déficit qui a continué à se
réduire par rapport à 2013
la loi de financement pour 2015 adopté
en décembre dernier prévoyait pour 2014
un déficit de 11 7 milliards d'euros
pour le régime général et de 15,4
milliards d'euros en incluant le fsv
c'est à dire le même niveau que celui
constaté en 2013
or le déficit du régime général sera
finalement de moins de 10 milliards
d'euros 9,7 milliards exactement ce qui
ramène le déficit de l'ensemble avec le
fsv à 13,2 milliards d'euros
c'est-à-dire 2 2 milliards d'euros de
moins que l'année précédente et 2 2
milliards d'euros de mieux que la
prévision
ce résultat est le meilleur résultat
atteinte depuis 2008 c'est à dire avant
le début de la crise économique en 2010
leur déficit du régime général et du fsv
était de plus de 27 milliards d'euros en
quatre ans il a donc été divisée par
deux et même un peu plus 21 milliards en
2011 17,5 milliards en 2012 15 points 4
milliards en 2013 et donc 13 2 milliards
en 2014 semble important de rappeler ces
chiffres puisque l'opinion souvent a le
sentiment que les efforts consentis par
les uns par les autres sont vains en
quatre ans nous avons divisé par deux je
dis non
collectivement ils ont divisé par deux
le régime les déficits pas bon de c
du régime général et du fsv je souligne
que l'on retrouve de manière identique
le même effet sur l'état de la sécurité
sociale puisque déficit de l'état s'est
lui aussi établi pour 2014 à un niveau
inférieur que prévu dont l'occasion dû
revenir d'autres débats c'est à dire à
85,6 milliards d'euros c'est-à-dire en
baisse de 3 4 milliards d'euros par
rapport à la loi de finances
rectificative ci est importante pour ces
raisons nous avons d'ores et déjà
annoncé que la prévision de déficit
public pour l'année 2014 je vous
rappelle cette prévision était de 4 4 %
sera inférieure à ses 4,4 pour cent
il sera annoncé par l'insee dont vous
connaissez la nécessité d'aller pendant
donc je n'ai pas d'informations plus
précises à vous donner aujourd'hui mais
vous aurez jeudi matin l'ensemble des
déficits état ass aux administrations
locales et il ya tout lieu de penser
parler de l'état nous parlons
aujourd'hui des régimes sociaux qu'il
sera inférieur aux 4 4% que nous avions
annoncée commission ça vous a pas
échappé la commission
nous comptabilisons à titre prévisionnel
et déficit dans déjà de 4 3%
nous verrons jeudi quel sera le déficit
d'ensemble ce résultat sur l'année 2014
est d'autant plus intéressant qu'il
repose
il se compare aux prévisions initiales
qui étaient fondées vous l'avez dit
également je vais je dire monsieur le
président je suis en général ou chanter
vous vous avez les deux fonctions je
rappelle que vous l'avez dit la loi
était fondée à l'époque sur une
prévision de croissance économique de 0
9% et une progression significative de
la masse salariale qui était à l'époque
de 2 2% et donc la prévision initiale
déficit était de 13 milliards d'euros
dont 9,6 pour le régime général soit
presque exactement à 100 millions près
le même niveau que celui auquel nous
avons l'outil dont 10 dans les
conditions économiques qui ont pourtant
était beaucoup plus défavorables que les
prévisions ces éléments sont une
nouvelle preuve que depuis 2012 nous
obtenons des résultats en matière
budgétaire quelle que soit la
conjoncture
ceci nous encourage à poursuivre
l'assainissement de nos finances
publiques en particulier nos finances
sociales dont ce gouvernement a la
charge d'apurer les déficits accumulés
cette volonté d'apurement est traduite
par le bilan de la caisse
d'amortissement de la dette sociale que
vous connaissez bien qui a remboursé au
cours de l'année 2014
12 7 milliards d'euros de dette soit un
montant quasiment équivalent à celui du
déficit du régime général en 2014 la
preuve a donc été faite que le
gouvernement avait non seulement la
volonté mais aussi qu'il avait mis en
place les moyens nécessaires
certains en doutent et pour poursuivre
le redressement des comptes
et ceci malgré la conjoncture
sur le deuxième point et je souhaite y
revenir plus en détails c'est par
l'ampleur de l'effort de maîtrise des
dépenses que ces résultats ont été
obtenus dans le détail chacune des
branches présentes une amélioration par
rapport à 2013
il s'agit tout d'abord d'une
amélioration du déficit de la branche
d'assurance maladie qui se réduit de 300
millions d'euros
l'objectif national de dépenses
d'assurance maladie ondam qui concentre
l'essentiel des dépenses de cette
branche a été respectée et ceci pour la
cinquième année consécutive selon des
données je les dis qu'ils ne sont pas
encore complètement définitive il
s'établirait à 178 milliards d'euros
pour 2014
c'est à dire 300 millions de moins que
prévu en plfss
et ce alors même que nous avons choisi
l'été dernier dans la loi de financement
rectificative de durcir l'objectif de
800 millions d'euros
l'objectif pour 2015 a été fixé à partir
de ce montant rectifier ce qui a
contribué à diminuer durablement les
dépenses d'assurance maladie
les économies réalisées en 2014 pour
ralentir les dépenses et respecter
l'objectif on encore présenter près de
2,4 milliards d'euros auxquels
s'ajoutent les 800 millions d'euros déjà
évoqué ces efforts repose principalement
sur des économies sur le prix des
médicaments sur les achats des hôpitaux
sur un plus grand recours aux génériques
et sur une plus grande efficience des
prises en charge à l'hôpital et en ville
je cite le développement de chirurgie
ambulatoire l'utilisation de
référentiels pour la durée d assurance
maladie par exemple ce sont des efforts
de productivité et d'efficience sans
dégradation de la qualité du système de
soins qui ont été entrepris je profite
d'ailleurs de cette intervention pour
rappeler comme marisol touraine l'a fait
avant moi que les dépenses de santé ne
diminue pas en valeur
mais que leur progression et maîtrise
est limité à 2 1% en 2015
en outre les mesures d'économies prévues
sur 2015-2017 n'applique pas comme il a
été parfois dit de suppressions de
postes à l'hôpital mais une meilleure
organisation et une plus grande
efficience des établissements de santé
d'ailleurs je rappelle que pour 2015 le
secteur hospitalier bénéficiera de près
de 1,5 milliard d'euros de crédits
supplémentaires
en outre comme le gouvernement s'était
engagé cette maîtrise des dépenses
d'assurance maladie ne repose sur aucun
des remboursements ou transfert te
financements vers les assurés sous forme
par exemple aux deux franchises que
d'autres parfois utilisé s'agissant de
la branche des accidents du travail et
des maladies professionnelles at mp
l'excédent déjà constaté les deux années
précédentes augmente fortement il
s'établit à 600 millions d'euros ce qui
permet de réduire la dette accumulée par
la branche dont l' équilibre financier
dépend exclusivement des cotisations des
employeurs vous le savez le déficit de
la branche famille se réduit lui aussi
par l'effet des mesures qui ont été
prises en 2013 afin de limiter la
progression des dépenses
pour autant le gouvernement à assurer le
financement des mesures prévues dans le
plan pauvreté soit plus de 100 millions
d'euros en faveur des familles les plus
modestes avec par exemple la majoration
du complément familial pour les familles
en deçà du seuil de pauvreté ou encore
la majoration de l'allocation de soutien
familial pour les familles
monoparentales
enfin le déficit de la branche
vieillesse se réduit fortement par
l'effet des mesures de la loi de janvier
2014 et revient à un niveau proche de
l'équilibré
puisqu'il s'agit du déficit le plus
faible des dix dernières années
là aussi
même si des mesures d'économie ont été
prises notamment le décalage des dates
de revalorisation qui ont permis de
réduire ce déficit des mesures de
justice et d'équité ont marqué l'année
je rappelle quelques exemples la
revalorisation exceptionnelle des
retraites agricoles de faible montant
l'abaissement des seuils pour valider un
trimestre de retraite pour les
travailleurs précaires comme les emplois
à temps partiel ou occasionnels ou
encore la prise en compte de tous les
trimestres de congé maternité des femmes
pour la retraite
le minimum vieillesse enfin a été porté
à 800 euros
troisième et dernier point les résultats
dans le domaine des recettes de la
sécurité sociale montre globalement la
prudence je l' ai déjà dit des
hypothèses retenues par le gouvernement
comme vous savez le gouvernement a
constaté au milieu de l'année 2014
une dégradation de la situation macro
économique caractérisée notamment par
une inflation très basse
en conséquence nous avions décidé vous
nous avez suivi de réviser les
prévisions de recettes dès le dépôt du
projet de loi de finances pour 2015
ces prévisions on était à nouveau
ajuster à la marge par la loi de
finances rectificative de fin d'année
globalement la progression des revenus
d'activité a été légèrement meilleur
qu'anticipé avec une hausse de la masse
salariale globale de 1,6 pour cent
malgré la relative stabilité du nombre
d'emplois l'ensemble des recettes sur
les revenus d'activité des salariés
agricoles les indépendants et les
employeurs publics ont été un peu plus
élevée que prévu
les contributions fiscales affectés à la
sécurité sociale sont restées bien
orientées en 2014 notamment les recettes
du forfait social qui ont progressé en
2014 par rapport à 2013 ainsi que celles
sur les produits de placement
cette progression vient confirmer que
les dispositions prises
en 2012 par ce gouvernement c'est à dire
la rose du forfait social et l'ajout de
deux points de prélèvements sur le
capital
nullement entamé les revenus distribués
tels que l'abonnement accordée par les
employeurs à leurs salariés
par ailleurs les mesures de plusieurs
est revenue parlons de plusieurs accises
notamment celles sur les alcools ont été
meilleures que celles que le
gouvernement avait prévu
j'insiste sur le fait que la loi de
financement massive et social pour 2014
déjà qu'on tenait très peu de mesures de
hausse du niveau des prélèvements
sociaux
la seule mesure d'importance adopté
l'année dernière qui consistait à
soumettre tous les produits de placement
au tour vigueur de 15,5 pour ça pour
sans pardon n'a par ailleurs pas eu le
rendement escompté initialement
puisque vous savez que le conseil
constitutionnel a décidé d'en exonérer
les produits de placement constitué au
titre des huit premières années de
contrat à nouveau vous avez vu
l'occasion de le constater la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2015 ne prévoit pas de hausses de
recettes affectées à la sécurité sociale
les mesures adoptées l'an dernier l'été
dernier dans le cadre du pacte de
responsabilité représente même des
baisses de prélèvements importants soit
plus de 6 milliards d'euros au total
pour la sécurité sociale baisse qui ont
été compensées par l'état puisque celui
ci a repris une partie du financement
des aides au logement
le programme de 2015 est clairement
tracée par la dernière loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
nous poursuivons nos efforts en 2015
pour améliorer encore la situation des
finances sociales et donc des finances
publiques en mettant en oeuvre les
économies qui ont été présentés et
adoptés dans la loi de financement n'est
évidemment pas question de relâcher
l'effort de redressement des comptes
bien au contraire
au moment nous constatons que les
efforts de maîtrise des dépenses ont
porté leurs fruits
j'ai insisté là-dessus même dans une
conjoncture peu favorable
nous ne pouvons qu'être encouragée à
mettre en oeuvre les économies prévues
dans le cadre du plan d'économies de 50
milliards d'euros sur 2015 2017
je vous rappelle que 20 de ces 50
milliards portent sur la protection
sociale au sens large du terme
en conclusion on peut dire que pour la
sécurité sociale comme pour l'état en
les objectifs de réduction des déficits
ont été atteints et même dépassés
trajectoire de réduction des déficits
que nous avions fixé et qui prévoit de
ramener le déficit de la sécurité
sociale
à moins de 4 milliards d'euros en 2018
s'en trouve donc plus conforté que
jamais la démonstration est faite que
par des efforts raisonnables
proportionnée aux besoins répartis sur
l'ensemble des dépenses
le redressement des comptes est possible
et je vous remercie de votre attention
nous vous remercions monsieur le
ministre
de toutes ces précisions je comprends
que vous soyez satisfait puisque
effectivement les chiffres semblent
aller dans le bon sens avant de passer
la parole à mes collègues sont
quelques-uns à avoir déjà levé la main
et notamment à présent avant de passer
la parole à monsieur kardous qui est le
président de la dame ex je voulais vous
poser pour ma part deux questions là je
reviens dans ma fonction de rapporteur
général e vous êtes vous n'avez
certainement appris dans une revue
spécialisée
la dernière note de conjoncture d'après
cette revue la dernière note de
conjoncture de la corse fait apparaître
une hausse de 6 2% des encaissements au
quatrième trimestre 2014 qui tiendrait à
selon un selon cette revue à de fortes
anticipations sur fin décembre
d'encaissement ou titres d'échéance de
janvier
le surcroît de recettes observé en 2014
est il réellement imputable à cet
exercice et ne risque-t-il pas de se
traduire par de moindre recettes et donc
une dégradation de la situation en 2015
voilà la première question qui concerne
2 milliards 6,2 ces sas 2 milliards
deuxième question ça concerne le fonds
de solidarité vieillesse vous avez vous
en avait parlé
le fonds de solidarité vieillesse dont
le déficit se creuse de 600 millions
d'euros
peut-être le seul chiffre effectivement
qu'ils soient al'inverse de tous les
autres mais que j'ai noté en chine
enregistre ce fonds de solidarité une
évolution donc divergentes
pouvez vous préciser en recettes et en
dépenses
le détail du solde de ce fsv voilà mes
deux premières questions et si vous
pouvez nous y répond je répondre à la
seconde
pour commencer le solde effectivement
vous aviez bien pointé du fsv s'est
dégradée de 600 millions d'euros en 2014
il s'était améliorée de 1,3 milliard
d'euros l'année précédente
principalement sous l'effet de
l'affectation au fond des recettes
nouvelles issues de l'augmentation du
forfait social dégradation observée en
2014 et d'il ya plusieurs facteurs selon
nos premières analyses j'ai dit en
préambule que évidemment il faudra
quelques temps pour tirer toutes les
conclusions mais nous avons déjà tiré un
certain nombre de renseignements
d'abord les recettes ont globalement
augmenté de 1,9 pour cent par rapport à
l'année précédente
la fraction de forfait social attributs
fsv a été plus faible en 2014 que
l'année précédente
par ailleurs les recettes des
prélèvements sociaux sur les avantages
de préretraite ont reculé en revanche
les produits de ces trois s entend
augmenter
sur les dépenses elles ont été nettement
plus dynamique plus qu'elles ont
progressé de 4 8% contre 4 5% l'année
précédente principalement liée à la
conjoncture puisque les prises en charge
de cotisations au titre des pins de
chômage ont coûté 600 millions d'euros
de plus que l'année précédente c'est à
dire une hausse de 5 7% en 2013 ces
dépenses avaient même progressé de 7,1
pour cent est prise en charge de
prestations titre du minimum vieillesse
du minimum contributif et des majoration
pour conjoint à charge sont quant à
elles stables enfin il faut ajouter le
coût de la prime exceptionnelle de 40
euros versées aux retraités gagnant de
moins de 1200 euros
ceci a représenté un coût de 232
millions d'euros dépenses ont donc
progressé de l'ordre de 1 milliard
d'euros à compter de 2015 nous estimons
que le redressement du fsv sera permis
par l'affectation à son financement de
l'équivalent du montant supplémentaire
d'impôt sur le revenu généré par la
fiscalisation des majorations de
pensions appelle ça représente environ 1
2 milliard d'euros ceci permettrait de
ramener le déficit du fsv à moins de 3
milliards d'euros en 2015 c'est-à-dire
moins de 1 milliard d'euros en 2017
alors sur votre première question je
président je suis un peu moins
informer et on me dit j'ai remarqué que
les comptes de la sécurité sociale sur
ton comptabilité patrimoniale
c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas d'impact
si
vrai oui pas d'impact si les versements
2014 de cotisation
s'il ya eu déversement 2014 de
cotisations dues en 2015 qui sont alors
qu'ils seront alors rattachée à
l'exercice 2015 donc sur les 7 questions
que vous évoquez de décalage temporel
possible entre des versements 2014 en
2014 en fin d'année si j'ai bien compris
qui auraient trait à des versements qui
seraient dues au titre de l'année 2015
il y aura le rattachement à l'exercice
2015 de ces versements ceci dit ça fait
apparaître effectivement une
amélioration qui peut sembler un sport
virtuel tout au moins fictives pour
dominant parce qu'elles seront retraités
dans l'est dans les comptes du président
c'est purement comptables purement de la
trésorerie mais en termes de l'accord de
comptabilité en termes de résultats le
rattachement l'exercice sera
parfaitement fait d'accord bon il a été
fait dit on sur les chiffres que moi je
fier à une note de conjoncture de
l'acoss quand même un organisme
j'attends merci monsieur le ministre
cette bon je vais passer la parole
maintenant à notre collègue garde ou
jamais car oui mais merci monsieur le
président mon dodge et trois questions
précises à vous poser mais dans le fils
de du débat que nous venons d'avoir
rapidement c'est l'éternel problème
entre comptabilité d'engagement et
comptabilité de recettes dépenses donc
mais comme vous l'avez fort justement
dit puisque le les caisses sont arrêtés
les chiffres au de 17 mars
nous sommes le 24 donc avec sept jours
donc il faut pouvoir se retourner je
pense qu' aucune volonté de polémique
dans mon propos c'est la cour des
comptes qui sera le juge de paix puisque
je dois donner ces ses conclusions avant
le 30 juin c'est elle qui nous dira et
qui je pense se saisira du problème que
vient de poser notre président dans le
droit fil de cette remarque il aurait
été souhaitable mais c'est pas du tout
une critique parce que je conçois bien
qu'en sept jours au service ne peut pas
faire de miracles mais ce que vous nous
annoncez de bonne augure
vous avez fléché un certain nombre
d'écarts positif ou négatif
un meilleur contrôle des dépenses un
meilleur résultat dans l'ondam des
recettes et dans les recettes vous avez
probablement des négatifs qui
proviennent des chiffres de croissance
et de progression salariale qui ont été
moins élevées que prévu qui viennent
réduire en revanche vous avez des
recettes supplémentaires qui viennent de
décisions qui ont été prises
antérieurement en fonction de certains
prêts des vents donc ce qui aurait été
souhaitable comme dans toute formation
d'un nadin d'un déficit tout en excès
dans là il ya une amélioration de guerre
deux camps on puisse avoir des éléments
comparatifs d'une part des dépenses
d'autre part des recettes par rapport
aux prévisions en fonction des
différents pôles d'affectation pour
pouvoir mieux comprendre comment s'est
formée
ce résultat positif donc je sais que
c'est trop tôt je pense que nous y
verrons plus clair après l'intervention
de la chambre des comptes
mais la guerre une véritable recherche
en particulier de bien distinguer
dans les recettes ce qui est des
conséquences de la situation
macroéconomique comme vous l'avait dit
et ce qui est la conséquence de
prélèvements supplémentaires qui ont été
décidées antérieurement je pense que ce
serait intéressant d'avoir ces éléments
là dans la différence de prévisions de
recettes non pas ça ce sont des sujets
si on le fait c'est pas une question
c'est une constatation
alors en ce qui concerne mais même les
questions qui sont très ponctuel je
reviendrai sur la première puisque vous
avez cité dans votre propos les éléments
positifs et en particulier un meilleur
rendement de ces trois aces ce qui est
positif mais venons c3s puisque fait
supprimer à terme elle a déjà été
supprimée en partie je crois que c'est
pour 800 millions d'euros pendant 1
milliards donc j'avais 800 millions en
tête on sait qu'elles rapportaient
globalement 5 milliards qui était
réparti par moitié entre le rsi et le
fonds de solidarité vieillesse
donc autant pour le rsiq pour le
solidarité vieillesse
au moment où le gouvernement a annoncé
cette suppression on nous a dit que
cette somme supplémentaire serait prise
en charge par le régime général
donc ça va quand même faire en rythme
annuel une charge supplémentaire de 5
milliards d'euros pour le régime général
donc comment allez vous assurez une
recettes pérennes ou assurer un
financement pérenne pour ce manque à
gagner qui va maintenant arriver
extrêmement rapidement ça c'est la
première question
la deuxième question c'est
la conséquence d'une décision récente de
la suisse qui à déplafonner le la parité
entre le franc suisse et et l'euro est
ce que comme conséquence de faire
exploser la dette de la plupart des
hôpitaux publics qui bizarrement avait
emprunté en indexant leurs empreintes
sur le franc suisse
donc à partir de deux sets et dément
madame touraine annoncé le 25 février
dernier le doublement du fonds de
soutien aux hôpitaux qui est
actuellement de 100 millions d'euros sur
trois ans donc par un apport
supplémentaire de 300 millions d'euros
sur dix ans alors avez-vous maintenant
en fonction de de cet incident le
montant de la dette hospitalière pour
comment à l'avenir prévenir ce genre
d'événement est aussi quel est le mode
de fonctionnement du fonds de soutien
aux hôpitaux qui ont contracté des
emprunts disons le toxique et comment
sera-t-il financer et enfin la dernière
question qui est aussi technique le plus
conjoncturelle le président de la
république a annoncé en début d'année
qui le gouvernement envisageait une
fusion du cic et des allègements de
cotisations sociales qui ont fait
l'objet d'une application combien
janvier dont une application du pacte de
solidarité
donc comment peut-on envisager la fusion
de ces deux éléments
avec à mon sens un gros écueil ça va que
le cic et ned aux entreprises qui est
imputé sur l'impôt sur les sociétés
alors que l'allègement le pack de
responsabilité sont des exonérations de
charges sociales
alors quelle va être la réflexion du
gouvernement pour fusionner ses deux
aides et surtout sous quelle forme ça va
être fait lesquels va être là
l'imperméabilité entre le budget de la
sécurité sociale et le budget d'état
répondre au président une mission trois
questions
le sénateur en indiquant néanmoins sur
sa remarque liminaire que cercle vous
l'avez dit il est trop tôt parfois pour
donner trop de détails
il ya toujours des phénomènes qui
peuvent sont compensées vous l'avez
évoqué sur le fait qu'il ya une
croissance inférieure une inflation
inférieure qui les ya aussi eu des
décisions enfin ceci dit en 2014 nous
aurons l'occasion de revenir sur ce
point sachant que j'ai fait allusion la
commission des comptes de la sécurité
sociale qui aura déjà des informations
plus précises quant à la cour des
comptes à laquelle vous faites référence
je rappelle quand même que d'année
dernière et c'était la première fois la
certifier tous les comptes de toutes les
branches et ça a été la première fois et
donc au jeu laissez travailler bien
entendu entre indépendance sur trois
questions précises appelle des réponses
précises au moins pour deux d'entre
elles la première concerne la c3 et
rappelle que la chronologie prévu dans
le pacte pour la suppression de ces
trois skis dont le produit est un peu
supérieur aux 5 milliard d'euros que
vous évoquez
quant aux mémoires c5 v6 ses 5 6
milliards
oui non enfin on a toujours eu en tête
pardon de vous dire que c'est ces 5 2 6
milliards vous avez décidé le parlement
a décidé sur la proposition du
gouvernement de supprimer 1 milliard de
ces trois aces sont eux 1015a deuxième
milliards mais le parlement décidera est
prévue d'être supprimée dans le dans le
prochain texte pour l'année 2016 le sol
tu est prévue d'être supprimée dans
l'année 2010 est celle à la chronologie
qu'est prévue la compensation est fait
par le régime général
le 20 10 quai mais elle est faite
également au régime général par
par l'état ceci a été fait par des
tuyauteries diverses et variées sur
lesquels bien sûr vous êtes attentif et
je me comprends et même si je reconnais
même un peu mieux pardon raisons
personnelles vos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale qui qui sont de
véritables greffiers des compensations
de l'état des exonérations de
cotisations qui pourrait décider et donc
nous avons bien en 2015 compenser
l'intégralité des exonérations de
l'utilisation y compris ces suppressions
à ses troisièmes j'ai vu évoqué tout à
l'heure la prise en charge d'une partie
ouvrant de l'intégralité pardon d'avoir
un d'autres dé la partie des allocations
logement prise en charge par l'état qui
à présent donc une moindre dépendance à
ce permis de compenser et d'autres
dispositifs notamment la caisse de
congés payés je crois là encore je parle
de mémoire
donc voilà la chronologie qui est prévu
pour être tout à fait honnête
parfois les entreprises nous disent j'ai
vu d'ailleurs la cgpme hier je crois sur
ce point qu'à choisir elle préfère une
réduction de liesse qu'une suppression
de la poursuite de la suppression dans
ces trois s ouvrira pour l'instant c'est
pas dans l'est c'est pas dans les
projets du gouvernement il ya un pacte a
priori gouvernement se tiendra au pacte
va si l'ensemble des acteurs partenaires
sociaux manifesté le souhait de voir un
basculement
je le dis parfois de façon un peu
simpliste le ministre des comptes
publics
après tout ce qui compte pour lui c'est
le pied de colonne donc après si on
préfère jouer sur la c3s ou sur l'impôt
sur les sociétés plutôt que sur la c3s
ça peut être un choix économique un
choix stratégiques sont trouvés sont
plaints votre deuxième question appelle
là aussi une réponse technique qui
précise les emprunts toxiques
nous avons évidemment suivi le
décrochage du franc suisse
le taux de l'euro par rapport au franc
suisse
suites aux décisions des suisses il
était froid autour de 1,30 il est tombée
aux alentours mais en dessous je crois
de 1 euro il était ces derniers jours
j'ai pas regardé aujourd'hui aux
alentours de 1 007 est un peu remontés
ceci a pour effet pendant que vous
reprendre un peu vous avez dit de faire
exploser la dette de tous les hôpitaux
publics non certains hôpitaux publics
par tous concernés heureusement parce
que l'effet est parfois effectivement
significatifs avec des augmentations
soient des annuités qui peuvent
atteindre des taux d'intérêt de l'ordre
de 25 pesos c'était déjà de 15
souvent ils ont monté si j'ose dire à 25
ou désir à commandite des indemnités de
remboursement anticipé qui elle aussi
explose qui atteignent parfois des
sommes énormes alors nous avions mis en
place
c'est très important l'année dernière un
fonds de soutien aux hôpitaux que vous
l'avez rappelé qu'ils étaient 200
millions d'euros sur trois ans c'est à
dire de 33 millions d'euros par an et
qui était d'ailleurs certains nous le
reprocher souvent dame dire si une
partie de l'ondam si j'ose dire qu'ils
avaient été distraite
le mot est maladroit pour financer le
fonds de soutien aux hôpitaux en
difficulté nous avions d'ailleurs
convenu que cette somme était peut-être
un peu courte pour faire face aux
difficultés qui se profilait déjà avant
les évolutions du 15 janvier nous avons
ce trait de l'annoncé de son côté pour
la question des hôpitaux je les fais de
mon côté cela question des collectivités
territoriales qui sont beaucoup plus
nombreuses que les hôpitaux auraient
touché par cette question
certains vous ont interpellé lors des
questions d'actualité sur le sujet nous
avons décidé de doubler le fonds pour
les collectivités je n'y reviens pas
mais surtout concerne les hôpitaux
d'aller au delà de ce que vous avez dit
c'est à dire de porter l'aide à 300
millions d'euros sur dix ans
d'ailleurs nous allons disposer de 400
millions d'euros laissant qui était déjà
sous son vin et les 300 supplémentaires
qui vont être étalé sur dix ans pourquoi
parce que parfois on bosse ça s'anticipe
et parfois on accompagnera les hôpitaux
apporter leur charge avec des
discussions et des négociations
notamment avec l'as fils parce que tout
ça je veux pas perdre trop de temps nous
donner l'occasion d'échanger sur
d'autres sujets mais tout ça est assez
complexe
comment seront financés ces 300 millions
d'euros d'abord pas souvent dames claire
et rend financer intégralement pour
cette part par une majoration de la taxe
de risque systémique sur les banques
donc qui devrait majorait de pour cette
part hôpital de l'ordre de 30
puisque 300 sur 10 ans et 30 millions
d'euros et il y aura une autre par qui
et concerne la part collectivités sur
laquelle je ne j'ai l'occasion déjà de
m'exprimer donc voilà je languis n'y
aura pas cette fois de coûts si j'ose
dire pour soulan dame sur cette tranche
de 300 millions et le financement sera
assuré par une majoration la taxe sur
les soies systémique le troisième
question didier trois questions précises
la troisième est assez large
ce sénateur reconnaissez le volontiers
la cic e transformé couple est marié
avec des allègements de cotisations
sociales
le sujet est complexe au président de la
république a donné une orientation et a
évoqué un calendrier éloigné n'a parlé
je crois de l'année 2010 est avons donc
encore un peu de temps pour y travailler
mais via beaucoup de sujets ya la
question de la temporalité des choses
vous êtes tous ici des spécialistes et
savez bien que le crédit d'impôt est
payé par l'état l'année suivant puisque
les impôts sont perçus avec une année de
décalage
voilà une première difficulté qui compte
se retrouveront sujet consiste à avoir
un rapprochement de deux deux entités
qui sont de nature la gestion temporel
complètement différente d'où l'année
double mais blanche vous connaissez le
sujet on l'a eue sur la paix peut par
exemple ça on l'a eue sur d'autres
sujets et aussi des questions d'assiette
qui sont importantes le désert à peu
près évoquez dans votre propos puisque
le cic ne porte que sur les entreprises
assujetties à l'impôt
pas seulement l'impôt sur les sociétés
d'ailleurs l'impôt sur le revenu aussi
les allégements de cotisations porterait
sur l'ensemble des salariés du secteur
public privé pardon donc y compris un
secteur qui étaient parfois il faut bien
le dire le secteur on va dire de
l'économie sociale et solidaire qui
souvent pas toujours
enfin pour beaucoup de ses activités
n'est pas assujetti à l'impôt
donc il n'y a là aussi vous voyez des
questions l'assiette qui seraient
différentes et donc beaucoup de travaux
à conduire et votre question qui était
très large qui est tout à fait
pertinente n'appelle pas aujourd'hui de
ma part de réponse plus précise sinon
que de vous dire que le calendrier
évoqué pas présent à république nous
mais nous allons tourner 2017
il s'agit là d'un exercice qui porte sur
des sommes très importantes aussi je
n'ai pas ni mais c'est ici c'est grosso
modo en année pleine vitesse de
croisière
près de 20 milliards d'euros les
jugements de cotisation c'est plusieurs
milliards d'euros si on part en compte
la deuxième phase du pacte de
responsabilité que vous aurez à examiner
dans la dans les lois de finances ou de
financement afin de cette année puisque
nous envisageons bien sûr
conformément au pacte d'aller plus loin
sur les exonérations de cotisations pour
aller jusqu'aux salaire jusqu'à 3,5 fois
le smic aujourd'hui nous arrêtons à 1,6
fois le smic
voilà pardon est moins précis sur la
troisième question qui vous le
reconnaître était beaucoup plus large
merci monsieur smith avant de passer la
parole à nicolas que j'avais une
question précise aussi concernant la
décision de la cour de justice
européenne le 26 février dernier qui
s'est prononcé sur une demande du
préjudice ya du conseil d'état relative
à la csg savoir est ce que la cgt ait un
impôt ou une contribution sociale banc
et c'est évidemment très différent parce
que ça permet de décider que des rentes
viagères à titre onéreux de source
néerlandaise déjà imposés aux pays bas
ne devrait pas l'être devra battre
soumise à contribution sociale ici en
france alors est-ce que 400 ans ce
plutôt qu'un quelles sont les
conséquences sur le plan juridique et
financier que de cette décision pour la
france et à ce que les textes financiers
à venir tireront aussi les conséquences
l'arrêt de ruyter parce que je crois que
c'est ce dont il s'agit ne nous a pas
complètement échappé il était attendu et
il était consécutif à une demande du
conseil d'état et avant d'en tirer des
conclusions plus définitive depuis lors
natation est bien clair il ya lieu
d'attendre l'arrêt définitif du conseil
d'état compte tenu de l'avis de la cour
de justice européenne
il ya assez peu de doute sur l'arrêt
mais il faudra en analyse et
parfaitement contenu je voudrais
ce n'est pas que cette affaire soit mal
interprété il ne s'agit pas d'une
conséquence des décisions de 2012
contrairement à ce que j'entends ce que
je lis parfois en 2012 nous avons
effectivement décidé de modifier le taux
de c est chez appliquer un certain
nombre de revenus perçus plus tard
venant de france à des français résidant
à l'étranger au titre de la cccr vous
l'avez dit d'ailleurs la question est de
connaître la nature exacte d'un débat
vieux comme un jeu comme l'assurait de
connaître la nature exacte s'agit-il
d'une contribution sociale liée à la
filiation à l'ouverture de droits ou
s'agit-il d'une contribution de type
impôts de toute nature en france nous
avons eu déjà des jurisprudences et des
analyses et du conseil constitutionnel
et d'autres acteurs spécialistes et du
riste de tout poil la cour de justice
semble lier le fait que le veulent
l'assujettissement à la csg devrait être
lié à une affiliation un régime de
sécurité sociale
mais ce n'est pas la modification
législative que ce gouvernement à cette
majorité pardon a décidé à la fin de
l'année 2012 je crois ou dans une loi de
finances rectificative de 2012 qui a
provoqué cette nouvelle appréciation on
la suite allait procédure qui est
engagée
chacun défend bien entendu sa lecture du
droit
je le dis parce que ce procès qui s'y
est fait à ce jour j'ai eu l'occasion à
l'assemblée nationale d'être assez
vivement interpréter interpellé pardon
et par
des députés représentant les français de
l'étranger et plusieurs d'ailleurs que
si tu es sans animosité dominique pas
dominique frédéric le faire mais aussi
claudine schmid sur ce sujet qui à
chaque fois disait le voyez c'est parce
qu'en 2012 vous avez fait ça
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez non non c'est
le sujet il est bien là et c'est celui
que vous avez objectivement et
parfaitement décrit
2 combien d'argent s'agit-il de beaucoup
voilà alors j'ai l'habitude quand on me
dit ça de dire mais je sais pas ce que
ça veut dire beaucoup
c'était pour ce matin donc oui s'il
s'agit de plusieurs centaines de
millions s'agissant plus prendre le
monde
le remboursement à faire un lieu de
prévoir les choses sauf si nous nous
interrogeons jour et que nous
travaillions sur la question de la
nature de la sécher et peut-être prendre
des dispositions législatives qui
permettrait d'avoir bon maire ce moment
là à ce moment là c'est pas sûr sur
cette seule masse qu'il faudra
travailler mais c'est sûr bien
évidemment mais l'ensemble c'est ce qui
pose la question du financement de
régimes de protection sociale en n'en
est pas là mais je crois qu'il serait
malsain de nier ce débat qui
nécessairement sera devant nous un
risque d'être devant nous si jamais on
sait l'état venait à interpréter
autrement l'arrêt de la cjce
ce serait surprenant mais nous aurons
probablement avoir ce débat
j'en donne droit à ce moment là les
volumes précis jeu
certains parlent d'un milliard de 1000
ha bon oui c'est plusieurs centaines de
millions notamment parce qu'il faudra
rembourser
mais voilà c'est la responsabilité
collective de la nature de la cgt elle a
été instituée en 1991 si ma mémoire est
bonne qui nous portera avoir une analyse
parce que voilà connaissait tous ces
sujets mais la question est parfaitement
légitime et à vrai dire je m'y attendais
bien merci monsieur le ministre je passe
par là monsieur barbier
oui merci c'est le président aminé ça
c'est un certain nombre de précisions
maintenant concernant l'assurance
maladie
quelques problèmes bien comprendre vous
parlez de diminution de 300 millions
donc dans la réalisation de l'ondam 2014
par rapport à ce qui avait été fixé donc
en début d'année de probation dans la
loi de finances 2013 avec une baisse en
cours d'année 2014 qui avait été de 800
millions comme vous le signalez alors
cette économie est un petit peu
artificielle parce qu'en fait si on se
place par rapport au budget rectificatif
une diminution une diminution qui est
moins et vous parler notamment que les
dépenses concernant le traitement par
l'hépatite c dépasserait le milliard
il semblait que initialement on avait
fixé pour 2014 à 450 millions sauf
erreur de ma part
le
le montant des dépenses concernant ce
traitement spécifique de l'hépatite c
alors est ce que ce sont des chiffres
définitifs que vous avez comment se
fait-il que y est
cette autorisation de dépassement d'une
enveloppe de 400 de 550 milliards c'est
450 millions qui était prévu
initialement
elle 750 je crois pour l'année 2015
comment sa suite il est ce que les
mesures de régulation notamment de
reversement de ristournes pour être
peut-être un peu vulgaire qui avait été
envisagé dans les mesures de régulation
pourquoi on arrive à ce chiffre 2
milliards l'autre part est ce que c'est
cette somme dépensée pour le traitement
des pâtes etc et dans le lent veloppe
fermé de l'ondam 2014 ce qui sait ce que
c'est des crédits un petit peu flottant
un petit peu à part ses premières
questions
deuxièmement vous avez dit que en
matière de jeu concernant l'assurance
maladie il n'y avait eu aucun des
remboursements bon c'est pas tout à fait
exact depuis 2012
un certain nombre de déremboursement de
médicaments y compris
dernièrement le 1er mars dernier les
antilles arthrosiques qui ont été dits
rembourser n'était pas remboursée
beaucoup ce n'est pas les économies très
substantiel pour l'assurance maladie
puisque c'était remboursés à 15%
mais c'est ces mesures de
déremboursement il y en a eu et pourquoi
on gomme c'est cet aspect qui participe
ce temps soit peu aux économies en
matière de dépenses et concernant le ce
que vous avez la ventilation
toujours concernant l'assurance maladie
entre la part soins de ville la part
hôpital par rapport au montant des
dépenses de chacun des secteurs et
une autre question mais c'est peut-être
une question d'un mauvais financier que
je suis quand on part on voit que depuis
quelques notamment l'année 2014
les déficits des hôpitaux tend à
augmenter à nouveau il y avait un
certain nombre de publications sur les
dettes des hôpitaux
c'est comptabilisés dans de votre
déficit ou 6 et des dettes qui sont à
part dans les hôpitaux publics qui
échappent un petit peu la comptabilité
et d'autre part quand vous parler
d'augmentation des tarifs d'activité de
0 35% ça concerne les établissements
publics et privés ou si ça consomme que
les établissements publics
j'ai mal compris la fin votre dernière
question sur ces dernières questions
nous avait dit que il y avait une
majoration un dégel des tarifs
d'activité de 0 35% dans les
établissements de santé
qu'est-ce que ça concerne tous les
établissements publics ou les
établissements publics et privés ou que
les établissements publics
j'ai passé merci monsieur barbier je
vais passer par la parole à monsieur
nourrissent et oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
merci pour cette présentation
synthétique un cd premiers chiffres bons
à vous écouter effectivement la
situation s'améliore le déficit diminue
les dépenses sont maîtrisées les
recettes augmentent et pourtant il ya
toujours la difficile quand même de 13
milliards 2 je pense que sur la
conclusion qu'il faut pas oublier dans
un taquin mais c'est quand même la
moitié des 4 ans maintenant que je
constate 13 unir les raisons que j'ai
évoquées
je voulais évoquer comme mon voisin la
situation des hôpitaux à 12 a évoqué les
hôpitaux à un moment j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il y avait plus de problèmes dans les
hôpitaux vous ai parlé des postes on
constate quand même que les bilans sont
déséquilibrés dans nos hôpitaux
les déficits sont chroniques il ya une
publication il ya quinze jours où il y
avait
une synthèse tous les hôpitaux qui est
en déficit il y en a certains
effectivement ce sont des sommes non
négligeables mais je voulais vous poser
la question vous avez évoqué dans votre
intervention qui avait un milliard
n